hello everyone thank you for joining a
this talk here i will present the
project that i did it with this adorable
now robot and we'll talk in general
about self exploring robots first i will
try to justify the use of machine
learning tools in robotics why does it
even make any sense then i will show
different examples from my lab including
my experiment and will leave some time
for questions so let's say now i want
the robot to perform a certain task like
serve you sandwiches or clean the room
between the lectures well as a
programmer my intuitive solution would
be to create a list of motor commands
and just run it on the robot and let it
perform the task but we believe that
this approach might be limited and we
take our inspiration mostly from nature
there are many many examples I brought
one that I like especially take it's
taken from the world of birds if you
look at the different bird species you
can classify to different developmental
strategies what is called precocial and
the other one is altricial and ok so the
morphological differences are quite
clear well the precaution species are
born with the hatch with feathers with
their eyes open there are more mobile
and in general more independent the old
trishul ones look helpless more like a
chicken nugget for predators and if we
look at the brain development we see
similar patterns on the x-axis here is
the development of the brain before
hatching and the y-axis show after
hatching and we can see that the
alteration species in black develop most
of their brain after hatching which
means the brain is developed while the
animal already experienced the real
world that it has to deal with and we
believe here lies the big big advantage
and
it's true we see it after in adulthood
that the ultra shal species are although
they had a bit of a weird start they
developed to be more intelligent more
creative they are the one to adopt to
urban areas and in general just they
have a larger skill set shut up so the
lesson that we take from it is that just
innate behavior instinctive behavior can
be limited and learned behavior although
it takes more time and practice in the
long run can reach more flexible and
adaptable creative and intelligent
results and behaviors so with this with
this lesson now we want to apply to the
robotic world and fortunately the all
the tools for machine learning already
exist they are widely used and we just
need to apply them into robotics here I
would like to apologize for the quality
of the picture but I show now different
examples from my lab we have robots that
learn through following their hand with
their eyes robots that learn to use
tools and the meaning of using tools
robots who learn through imitation and
communication and robots who actually
learn to point at stuff that they just
want to grasp just like babies do so now
I would like to get to my experiment in
my experiment I wanted to let the robot
explore and learn about the currents the
electrical currents that his motors are
consuming while moving so to control the
robot I used the Python SDK it's
basically a library called now key and I
will now run these commands on the robot
and I ask you to be scared with me
because if anything happens to this
robot
okay so let's first try to change the
position of the robot it's a it's buster
okay so now it will sit down hopefully
without falling now this movement is
actually pre-programmed it's not a good
example for the learned behavior that
I'm trying to to reach but it's just due
to give you a good example let's go back
to the crouched position no let's not ok
now the actual movement that i was using
is called left arm bubbling it basically
means that it's moving is the left arm
around randomly just just like babies do
when they lay on their back and they're
just moving randomly slowly trying to
explore themselves and the world around
them I will give an example to this
movement so you will see it's not so
impressive it's just moving its arm
around randomly as it's doing so it is
the measuring it's taking samples from
the motors from the joints of the arm it
has 55 joints to in the shoulders to in
the elbow and one of the hand and yeah
it's basically collecting three types of
of information the actual occurrence the
electrical currents that I want him to
explore and then the joints position so
the angles of each of these joints and
the the target joint where it's trying
to to reach so the position the targeted
position I will stop it because it's
distracting you I can see
doesn't want to stop okay cool and the
the actual occurrence and what I wanted
is actually to to choose a model that
can predict the electrical currents from
the joints positions so take the numbers
on the on the left but this is just a
short this is just 30 samples I actually
took 10,000 samples and I trained the
neural network this is the model that I
was that I chose an artificial neural
network to try to predict the currents
out of the joints position so it didn't
get any information about the currents
also obviously it doesn't know the
meaning of these numbers it's just
numbers for the model but it was trying
to predict the currents and I did it
with training set and with the test test
set the tool i was using is called
lasagna i hope some of you know it it's
a very easy to use library it's very
flexible I could easily adjust all
parameters of my neural network the
number of layers the number of nodes the
the function hold up everything that
needs to be that can be adjusted in a
neural network until I found the best
model for my specific data and here we
are already getting to the results so
you can see that through training the
error drops down the network learns to
predict well these electric currents we
can look at the actual currents here you
can see every pair is the on top the
actual current and in the bottom the
models prediction of test data of data
that it was not trained on and we can
see very good results each each pair
looks very similar especially if you
look at the pics another way to look at
it is to plot the currents as a function
of this difference between the actual
location and the desired location and
here we can see that there is a some
sort of relation between this difference
and the end the currents and on the left
is the actual occurrence on the right is
the prediction of the model and we can
see that the model actually learned the
neural net will learn
how to fit this function so it was doing
a non so trivial calculation it was
taking the two numbers that it got for
each joint subtract and fit this
function so now we have this fitting
fitting model that predicts well the
currents what can we do obviously we can
predict the currents but we can also
recognize now surprising situation so if
for example the hand of the robot is
touching something or it has some extra
weight or it's getting old replaced by a
new hand or the battery's low anything
that will break down this this relation
will create a distance between the
prediction and the actual current and so
the network can report a surprise and
obviously can also be trained on and
adjust to the new circumstances because
the neural network is something flexible
and you can keep training it over and
over with new data so to summarize to
summarize we learn the difference
between learning robots and pre
programmed robots and maybe learning
robots can overcome one day with their
intelligence dupree program robots just
like the examples from the birds we saw
that a neural network can learn about
the robot mechanics and well the next
step will be to combine all these
different modalities we develop in the
lab that i showed in 21 mega baby robot
or robot army that can take over the
world or at least take over your jobs
and that's all
awesome so thanks thanks a lot we have
plenty of time for questions if there's
some and I guess there are no immediate
questions then I think everyone just
wants to see the robot events often
entertain us okay let's write to make
the robot lay on his belly for example
let's try this transition
so this posture is called laying belly
hmm no I'm sorry I have a connection
problem we will not be able to
demonstrate anymore just I guess it's
tired okay so we have a question here
maybe in the meantime the sad robot gets
reconnected go ahead I want you to know
does he have any sensors can you learned
yes it has the robot has a microphone to
speakers it has two cameras here and
here and we use all these different
modalities in our in our lab it it
doesn't have a skin sensors so it can't
really this is actually one reason why
we started this project because we
wanted the robot to feel when it's
touching something and it was not
possible because it doesn't have skin
sensor it doesn't feel anything but well
we thought maybe using a changes in the
electric currents it could recognize
that it is touching something because
it's making more effort to to move yeah
I think that's that's all all the sensor
it has other than that it has a test to
speech module falling reflex model face
detection model it's how does it cost
thousands of euros depends on the
version this one is eight thousand
dollars
so now we got the questions coming in
everyone wants the robot sorry can you
talk a little bit more about how it
strained how it's going in real time on
your laptop are you going to taking the
data so the training is it's like a two
step training I first collect all the
data then I put the robot to sleep and
then I train the data on a neural
network but this can all be combining
and put the neural network inside its
head but it also makes some sense
because we know that babies also re
analyzed data from their daily
experience during sleep but the model is
the model is the neural network that is
trained on the massive data after after
the movement on my computer yeah
question here thanks for a presentation
in the in the results plot you could see
that the training error the training
cost doesn't reach zero so the model is
still on the fitting at the end so do
you have an idea why is it the case or
well there is always of course it's the
real world so there is always a noise
involved bad samples but we are looking
for the general fitting we don't look to
to be completely exact and I don't think
you really can it's all you have
electrical devices a physical
explanation of the nature of the
remaining noise that you know you can
with it just just every physical
experiment has some some noise in it but
the are you sure that the scale of the
noise that you still have at the end is
actually matching some physical
phenomenon where you know that you are
expecting and noise at that level and
you cannot get rid of it or no not that
I know of yet but we can we can check it
out and I have a second question and how
do you plan to use this feedback this
discrepancy between the prediction and
and and the actual sensors for
controlling exploration I guess you plan
to do some kind of reinforcement
learning you tell a bit more on your
plan to use this
so far we are still in the stage where
when we are trying to to surprise the
model and to measure the surprise so we
are not there yet but but it is in our
plans for sure more questions will be
around and try to reconnect the robot so
that everyone can have a chance to play
with it yes I will thank you okay one
question you so have you been a
successful in inferring touch from
electrical current drive variations yes
so far we weave it is recognizing that
something is different it still doesn't
know it can to recognize what kind of
object it's touching or if it's even
touching its own body sometimes the hand
gets stuck on the under knee and there
is still no no actual difference of when
it's touching itself or when it's
touching an external object okay so i
would say thank you again thank you